race against the machine is a very
interesting book it's gotten a lot of
popularity because it's targeting an
issue that is front and center for a lot
of people in the United States and
around the world namely the issue of
jobs creation and unemployment
essentially the thesis of the book the
author is Erik Brynjolfsson and Andrew
McAfee make the point that their goal is
to introduce technology as a key engine
of the changes that we're looking at in
terms of unemployment and job creation
and so the book really focuses very
heavily on the pace of technology
innovation at one level highlighting the
exponential improvement in price and
performance of technologies but then
focuses on the impact that has in terms
of increasingly taking away jobs through
automation that more and more jobs jobs
that we thought we're going to be immune
from automation are increasingly
becoming vulnerable to automation
because of the power of technology and
at that level I think it's a very
powerful book their technology is
advancing at a very rapid pace and it is
becoming more and more able to take over
activities that we as humans have been
performing I think the issue is though
by framing the the challenge as a
technology challenge what they miss is
the reason why these jobs are so
vulnerable to technology essentially if
you step back and look at what the
modern corporation is and how it evolved
through a model that we describe as a
push model basically it has to do with
developing forecasts and predictions and
then making sure that the right people
are in the right place at the right time
and following tightly scripted
activities to respond to that demand in
stepping back from that that's a formula
for automation if you have tightly
scripted jobs that are highly
standardized where there's no room
boom for individual initiative or
creativity machines by and large can do
those kinds of activities much better
than human beings they're much more
predictable they're much more reliable
we as human beings have flaws we tend to
get distracted we tend to go off into
unexpected areas and so I think that the
real reason that we have such an issue
in terms of unemployment and and job
loss through automation is that we've
crafted these jobs exactly so that they
would be vulnerable to automation we've
put kind of a bulls-eye target on
workers around the United States around
the world and said come after me shoot
me this is like I'm the target for
automation technologies not the root
cause technology simply going after the
target that's been put in on the on the
screen the root cause is how we've
defined work in companies now that the
opportunity now is to step back and say
is that the way we need work to be done
one of the issues is this formula for
how work is conducted was developed in
the last century and it was based on a
set of infrastructures and assumption of
a stable environment that made it easy
to define standardized highly scripted
work now we're in a world that's more
rapidly changing more uncertainty more
of those extreme events that talib calls
the black swans that make it really
critical for us as individuals in the
workplace to take much more initiative
to be constantly exercising creativity
and imagination to respond to the
unexpected events that's a very
different model of work it requires a
very different way of organizing our
institutions and a different set of work
practices that are much harder to
automate when you have that kind of
imagination creativity trust based
relationships that are required to
really address these these hard problems
it makes it much less vulnerable to the
kind of automation and so my belief is
that if you focus on that as the root
cause now the problem is not technology
the problem is how do we innovate our
institutions and our work practices so
that we in fact can the authors have a
very nice phrase that they call rather
than Race Against the Machine we ought
to start racing with the machine
unfortunately I don't think they develop
that very well in the book they kind of
offer it as a case for optimism at the
very end without a lot of deep content
but the content I think about racing
with the machine is stepping back and
reassessing what are our institutions
for what kinds of work practices are
required in order to pursue that
institutional mission and in that
context I think you now are able to race
with the machine